I so didn't want to get into this but I
will Benji's in the new sharknado again
every year they put they make a new
sharknado yeah up the sharknado 60
patient keeping track he missed the
first sharknado he was in the second
through number six but he's the worst
[ __ ] actor I've ever seen
99% of Benji's acting is just screaming
he just yells and this yelling is so
over the top that you don't meet anyone
in real life who yells like this I'll go
back to sharknado 2 his character is
called homeless guy
what does the director say to him
director is a director I just basically
go over there like one of the PAS just
tells Benjy to go over there and act
like he's it's the end of the world
you've probably all seen movies of the
end of the world that's one of my
favourite themes in movies like I watch
a lot of Netflix can cause a lot of
drama you don't hear anyone yelling like
this they have soldiers being [ __ ]
killed they don't yell like this
that's when the shark answer so you're
like okay
then in sharknado 3 so in the first two
he's just yelling yes then finally I
guess somebody got ahold of them say
look we're gonna let you be a reporter
so don't yell he doesn't yell but how
many times have you turned on the TV and
seen a guy with a baseball cap on
delivering delivering the news never
you're now watching Chicago today hi I'm
Howard Beale we're joined by Mayor
Sandra Mansfield now mayor you're saying
the cause of all these sharknadoes
you're saying the gun been in this scene
this is still from sharknado 4 got here
you can't even say mayor when he calls
our mayor like a horse
mayor mayor mayor a mare let me see if I
have the scene in sharknado 5 year this
is the scene that been she did with like
Hoda and Kathie Lee in the cast of The
Today Show they throw it to Benjy who's
a reporter again but you'll see like
okay the world is ending sharks are
eating people but they're acting like
the normal Today Show normal everywhere
sharks are
just imagine your advertising budget is
put Benjy in the movie you know what
we'll put kanji in the movie how it'll
talk about it and we're gonna have huge
ratings I understand but if I was
preparing for that role watch guys who
are broadcasting in the middle of a
tornado which is the closest thing to a
sharknado but your reporter you don't
need to yell you're broadcasting
something like that people are getting
eaten by sharks that you get a little
jumpy anyway you want to hear a clip of
Benji's acting in sharknado 6 it looks
like they gave them less to do well that
would be an indication of what they
think of his ass
[Applause]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
okay more yelling Bengie no one
understands what you're saying he's
played with the script so I'm not
blaming the script I did what they told
me to do when I did my best
no I'm not saying you didn't do your
best I'm just saying your best sucks